- [Instructor] Le
Chatelier's principle says,
if a stress is applied to a
reaction mixture at equilibrium,
the net reaction goes in the direction
that relieves the stress.
Change in the concentration
of a reactant or product
is one way to place a stress
on a reaction at equilibrium.
For example, let's consider
the hypothetical reaction
where gas A turns into gas B.
And let's say the reaction
is at equilibrium.
And we suddenly introduce a stress
such as we increase the
concentration of reactant A.
According to Le Chatelier's principle,
the net reaction is
gonna go in the direction
that relieves the stress.
And since we increase
the concentration of A,
the net reaction is gonna go to the right
to decrease the concentration of A.
Let's use some particular diagrams
so we can get into the details
of how the reaction goes to the right.
So we're gonna symbolize
gas A by red particles
and gas B by blue particles.
And for this hypothetical reaction,
the equilibrium constant is equal to three
at 25 degrees Celsius.
Let's start by writing
the reaction quotient.
Qc is equal to, and we get that
from our balanced equation.
That would be the concentration
of B to the first power
divided by the concentration
of A, also to the first power.
Let's calculate the
concentrations of B and A
from our first particular diagram.
So B is represented by the blue spheres
and there are three blue spheres.
If each particle represents
0.1 moles of a substance,
and the volume of the
container is one litter,
since we have three particles,
that'd be three times
0.1, which is 0.3 moles
divided by a volume of
one litter is 0.3 molar..
So the concentration of B is 0.3 molar.
For A, we have one
particles, that's 0.1 mole
divided by one litter, which is 0.1 molar.
So the concentration of A is 0.1 molar.
And 0.3 divided by 0.1 is equal to three.
So Qc at this moment in
time is equal to three.
Notice we could have just
counted our particles,
three blues and one red
and said three over one.
That would have been a little bit faster.
So Qc is equal to three and
Kc is also equal to three.
So I should have written a C in here.
So when Qc is equal to Kc, the
reaction is at equilibrium.
So in this first particular diagram here
where Qc is equal to Kc, the
reactions are at equilibrium.
Next, we're gonna introduce a stress
to our reaction at equilibrium.
We're going to increase
the concentration of A.
So here, we're gonna
add four particles of A
to the reaction mixture at equilibrium.
The second particulate diagram
shows what the reaction
looks like right after we
add those four red particles.
So we started with one red
particle and we added four.
So now there's a total
of five red particles.
And we still have the
same three blue particles
that we had in the first
particular diagram.
Let's calculate Qc at this moment in time.
So just after we introduced the stress.
Since there are three blue
particles and five red particles,
Qc is equal to three divided
by five, which is equal to 0.6.
Since Qc is equal to 0.6,
and Kc is equal to three,
at this moment in time,
Qc is less than Kc.
So there are too many reactants
and not enough products.
Therefore, the net reaction
is going to go to the right
and we're going to decrease
in the amount of A,
and we're gonna increase
in the amount of B.
The third particular
diagram shows what happens
after the net reaction moves to the right.
So we said, we're gonna
decrease the amount of A
and increase in the amount of B.
We're going from three blues
in the second particular diagram
to six blues in the third.
And we're going from five
reds to only two reds.
Therefore, three reds must
have turned into blues
to get the third particular
diagram on the right.
And if we calculate Qc for
our third particular diagram,
it'd be equal to six divided by two,
which is equal to three.
So at this moment in
time, Qc is equal to Kc.
They're both equal to three.
So equilibrium has been reestablished
in the third particular diagram.
It isn't always necessary
to calculate Q values
when doing a Le Chatelier's
changing concentration problem.
However, for this hypothetical reaction,
it's useful to calculate
Q values to understand
that we're starting at equilibrium
and then a stress is introduced
such as changing the concentration
of a reaction or product.
And that means the reaction
is no longer at equilibrium.
Le Chatelier's principle
allows us to predict
which direction the net reaction will go
or we could also use Q to predict
the direction of the net reaction.
The net reaction will continue
going in that new direction
until Q is equal to K again
and equilibrium has been reestablished,
let's look at another reaction.
This is the synthesis of ammonia
from nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas.
And let's see the reaction
is at equilibrium.
So let's also look at this on a graph
of concentration versus time.
At equilibrium, the concentrations
of reactants and products
are constant, which is why we
see these straight lines here
for the concentration of
hydrogen, ammonia, and nitrogen.
And let's introduce a stress
to the system at equilibrium.
So right now we are at equilibrium
and all the concentrations are constant.
And let's increase the
concentration of hydrogen.
So we can see that on our graph.
So right here, there's a sudden increase
in the concentration of hydrogen.
Adding hydrogen means that
Q is no longer equal to K
and therefore the reaction
is not at equilibrium.
So let's go ahead and write over here,
Now we're not at equilibrium.
And Le Chatelier's principle
allows us to predict
which direction the
net reaction will move.
So since we added a stress,
the stress being increased
concentration of hydrogen,
the net reaction is
gonna move to the right
to get rid of some of that
hydrogen that was added.
And when the reaction goes to the right,
the amount of ammonia will increase.
And that's what we can see right
here on this red line here,
the amount of ammonia is increasing.
And the amount of ammonia increases
because nitrogen and hydrogen
are reacting to form ammonia.
Therefore, the amount
of nitrogen and hydrogen
will decrease.
Here we can see the amount
of hydrogen is decreasing.
And down here, we can see
the amount of nitrogen
is decreasing.
The reaction will continue
to go to the right
until equilibrium is reestablished.
And that happens at the
second dotted line here.
And we know that because we can see
all of these concentrations
are now constant.
So the reaction has reached equilibrium.
So far we've only talked about
change in the concentration
of a reactant so for example,
if we increase the
concentration of hydrogen,
the net reaction goes to the right.
We could also say shifts to the right.
So for a reaction at equilibrium,
if you increase the
concentration of reactants,
such as the concentration of hydrogen
or the concentration of nitrogen,
the reaction will shift to the right
to decrease the amount of
one of those reactants.
And if our reaction is at equilibrium
and we were to increase
the amount of our product,
increase the amount of ammonia,
so this time the stress place
is increased concentration of a product,
Le Chatelier's principle
says the net reaction
is going to move in the direction
that decreases the stress.
So in this case, the net
reaction would go to the left
to decrease the amount of ammonia.
And if our reaction is at equilibrium
and we were to decrease the
concentration of our product,
the net reaction would shift to the right
to make more of the product.
Or if we decrease the concentration
of one of our reactants,
let's say of nitrogen,
in this case the reaction
will shift to the left
to make more of our reactant.